so we know that lots of people are
irresponsible there are lots of ignorant
people there's lots of people who don't
really care about how their actions
affect others there are people who just
get in over their heads in different
ways we know all that which is why
sometimes we need government officials
to step in I mentioned earlier in the
show in the wake of this entire pandemic
the libertarians are being pretty damn
quiet and and most people by and large
understand that the government does have
a pretty significant role to play here
and one of the places where the
government has a role to play and
quickly and we're depending on a
Republican governor to play that role is
the beaches of Florida much of the
country especially blue states are
taking social distancing seriously
Florida beaches have mostly stayed open
and some have closed early but tons of
Spring Breakers have just been
continuing to party and likely a
symptomatically spread the disease check
out this video of students who were
interviewed and who not only don't care
about the virus they are annoyed that
the virus is affecting their partying
and putting a damper on their buzz so to
speak this video is from CBS you'll also
this is kind of I don't know if this is
related but a lot of these people who
are being interviewed by CBS CBS their
faces are chafed they seem to be covered
in bruises and sunburns and their faces
seems swollen in some cases I don't know
why I don't know if it's they don't
understand sunscreen or what's going on
not sure if there's some connection
between their irresponsible behavior and
the fact that they seem very very beaten
up but let's take a look at the video
and the interviews I get kelowna
I get Corona at the end of the day I'm
not gonna let it stop me from partying
you know I've been waiting we've been
waiting for Miami Spring Break for
awhile about two months we've had this
trip planned to three months so we're
hiring having a good time whatever
happens happens
with my Spring Break what is there to do
here other than go to the bars or the
beach when they're closing all of it
it's really messy I think they're
blowing it way out of proportion I think
it's doing wait tomorrow is bad we need
a refund
this virus ain't that serious serious
it's more serious things out there like
hunger and poverty we need to address
that 21 this year so I'm you know party
so it's kind of disappointing but we're
just making the most of it we've met
these other people in our little Airbnb
spot so we're just hanging out with them
and trying to get drunk before
everything closes I mean it sucks but
we're gonna make the best of it we're
enjoying ourselves it sucks and I'm from
the water so this really sucks however
we're gonna enjoy ourselves we have a
date for this outing it's my birthday
stamp agency we're just trying to roll
with the boy were just living for the
moment we're just going for we're just
gonna do what happens when it happens
when stuff closes we're gonna do when it
closes but besides that we're just
trying to have the best trip we can this
is one of the most morally depraved
elements of all of this because it's
very easy for us to say you know what if
they don't want it they want to be out
there spreading and potentially getting
the virus let them die if they want to
be this stupid but that's not how the
virus works statistically they will
actually be fine although we are seeing
particularly because of medical systems
the healthcare systems being overwhelmed
that some people are not even young
people are not doing well but they are
going to infect people who are not going
to be fine and this is why we need
Florida's Republican governor not a
great guy not a great governor not
someone we really have have been able to
count on to do the right thing Ron de
santis he's got to shut down the beaches
and his initial order on bars was very
weak I think now he finally does seem to
be shutting down bars in Miami and Miami
Beach so this is the problem with the
initial spread of disinformation Trump
and Fox News over the last 3-4 days have
changed their tune they're taking the
virus seriously but the problem is that
once
the disinformation starts to spread
calling it a hoax calling it no big deal
saying we're not going to have cases
it's like a flu whatever once they get
that out it's very hard to then change
people's minds and get them to act and
realize that those initial proclamations
were very very wrong some of them won't
even hear that Trump and Fox News have
now changed their tune and are
acknowledging this as serious because
they're down there partying on the beach
and going to bars I was scheduled to go
to Miami Beach in six days obviously I'm
not going but if I did decide to go and
I decided to push through and just go
there I would feel like a terrible
person my moral framework would not let
me feel okay knowing that even if I was
statistically likely to be fine that I
was putting people at risk by being
there I wouldn't be able to enjoy myself
apparently that does not affect these
these people in the same way and that
doesn't really inspire confidence in in
our ability to fight this thing properly
the problem here is that we're depending
on everybody to do their part and it
impacts everybody not just them that's
the unfortunate reality so we need them
to take it seriously
of course the Trump administration
response has been atrocious
of course we're woefully unprepared as a
country and as a planet for this but on
top of it we have people like these kids
who are making the problem worse there's
a long incubation period for this
disease during which you are you have it
but you're not showing symptoms there's
a high contagion rate all of these kids
could infect people for the next seven
days
and in a week find out that they
themselves are sick and then the people
they infected before they were
symptomatic would have another few days
before they realized they had it and
they're walking around spreading it as
well and before you know it this is how
it spreads and this is how you get an R
naught value that is somewhere between
you know it looks like between one and a
half and four and a half probably in
reality between something like 1.8 and 3
with with coronavirus so I wish we could
just say screw them it's only it's they
are only endangering themselves
do whatever they want that's not the
case and that's why we all have to be
responsible at this point check this out
the first 500 people who see this video
and go to david pakman.com slash skill
will get a premium membership to
Skillshare for two months completely
free skill shares the online learning
community with thousands of classes on
almost anything you can imagine always
taught by experts they have classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design running a small
business and much more I recently took a
very interesting class called simple
productivity how to accomplish more with
less and got a bunch of great personal
productivity tips out of it we should
allow ourselves a little time every week
to either get creative keep your brain
sharp learn something new it's great for
mental health and almost all the classes
are under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video